and the animal foundation is waiving  adoption fees for  all dogs all cats today and tomorrow  now it's best to make an appointment  online at animalfoundation.com that's  where you can also see some pictures  of the animals but they're going to be  opening their lobby now so  watkins are welcome after 11 o'clock  again free dogs and cats at the animal  foundation  if you are not quite ready to adopt just  yet nevada spca is in dire need of  foster homes  summertime also known as kitten season  where many people find a litter of  kittens and then they take them to the  shelter  but sometimes the mother is close by and  then the kittens are gone  so if you're interested in fostering  these little sweethearts you can  fill out an application at  nevadaspca.org i've done it a couple of  times it's so rewarding but brian it's  tough to let them go  it's a little bitty kitty